hey everyone this is kevin from the
chefs website comm and today we are in
around six of our coverage the 2017 u.s.
Chess Championships our competitors
white is played by Fabiano Caruana
the third ranked player in the world
also the reigning champion of the u.s.
Chess Championships he put it a dominant
display last year his opponent is gonna
be played by gonna come ski he's had
kind of a rough start to the tournament
has had one win two losses two draws
he's gonna be looking to get back on
track Fabiano he's tied all of his games
so he needs a victory to start climbing
up the leaderboard as well but so far we
have Caruana with 2 and 1/2 points
facing a Tecumseh with two points white
starts out with pawn to e4 pawn c5
Sicilian defense we haven't seen too
much Sicilian offense in this tournament
so far and that f3 knight c6 pawn d4
main line of the Sicilian but then
Knight to f6 and after Knight c3 we see
Pawnee five variation we don't see all
too often usually we see a more of the
knight Dorf defense
maybe the dragon or accelerated dragon I
don't see as much of this the Lasker
Pelican variation it's somewhat
interesting it leaves this pawn
backwards not usually something you see
in the Sicilian defense and it also
leaves the square here on d5 a little
bit unprotected which we don't see too
much in the Sicilian defense usually
going to be playing pawn to e6 at some
point but e 5 is the play and then
Knight to b5 and if you guys once if you
watch this video and you say yeah this
would be a really cool opening to go
over feel free to leave comments below
or you can always email me that's where
I get a lot of the feedback for videos I
make the chess website at gmail.com we
can do an in-depth video on this
specific variation in the Sicilian
defense but Knight to b5 is thought to
be the best move it's very very easy for
black to equalize and any other move
that white does but this threatens
Knight to d6 and so usually black is
gonna play pawn to d6 if he does not and
does not allow us Queen to kind of
protect that if we see maybe pawn to
a six then Knight to d6 which did the
Bishop take Queen up here to d6 all of a
sudden White has the double Bishop pair
and it just has a very aggressive board
presence right here he can later go to
start square Bishop involved into the
game Council on the Queen said if he
wants to gonna have a really good game
from here so black is almost forced to
play this pawn to d6
and then Bishop to g5 getting involved
into the game and then pawn a6 is kind
of where theory is at on this variation
right now forcing this knight to come
back doesn't really have any moves
except for Knight to a3 so that's kind
of some of the compensation that black
has in this opening is forcing one of
whites Knights over here on a3 which
it's not doing anything it's good to get
few moves to really get involved into
the action and then pawn to b5 for the
longest time it was thought that you
know getting your bishop involved into
the game here was probably the best move
but instead of the bishop coming in it's
now pawn to b5 getting ready to fork
with pawn to b4 and so we do see an
exchange here on f6 and then why it's
gonna be looking to move one of his
knights now black has two options it
could be to take with his queen or take
with his pawn and you may look at this
say well it definitely would rather take
with my queen because i don't want to
have double pawns here on the F file and
then I have nowhere really to castle
safely at least but the problem is if
you take with your Queen right here then
the knight comes up to d5 nice Square
outpost for this night right here
forcing the Queen to move Queen back
here to d8 not a lot of other great
squares for the Queen to go to pawn up
to C Ford also protecting breaking up
this pawn right here and then if we see
the pawn so you'll say b4 then Queen to
a4 gets a little bit tricky pins down
this Knight right here also attacking
the pawn here on a 6 we see Bishop to d7
and that appear to be 5 and this is kind
of that critical square right here where
the pawn can't take but it doesn't have
a lot of great move so pawn takes Queen
takes up here on a 8 the Queen takes
here on a there's a fork and then the
Queen falls and this night it's going to
be able to come back to b6 we did go
through a lot of those moves very
quickly but that's kind of weird
theory is that so far in this variation
my guess is both players have not
studied you know maybe you got a cop ski
since he did play pawn to e5 but my
guess is they haven't gone too far down
that rabbit hole to see if there's other
lines in that variation they could play
so got a cop's he went with more the
traditional approach and that's just to
take with his pawn here on f6 and then
see if he can equalize maybe open up and
the serve the board play pawn to f5 and
try to get some momentum because right
now he's got a weakened King side it's
not really looking like he's gonna
castle on the Queen side he does have a
double bishop pair and his opponent has
a knight here on a three but I don't
necessarily like his setup right now
Fabiano continues with Knight to d5 and
black has to realize that he needs to
get rid of this night here on d5 it is
putting a ton of pressure on him it's a
great outpost and doesn't have tons of
great options to go ahead and remove
this he would like to just play Knight
to e7 because it kind of threatens
White's forced to do something but right
now he's almost forced to just play
Knight takes on f6 and that's checkmate
so that's gonna be bad usually don't
want to force your opponent to checkmate
you so instead he plays Bishop to d7
this does protect the pawn and it allows
the Knights come here to East 7 that's
exactly that's Bishop to d7 Bishop to d3
ninety-seven kind of forcing the
exchange here so that Knight does come
off the square here on a d5 black still
does have the backward pawn on d6 pawn
to c3 allowing for the Knights coming
back here to see to get involved because
right now on a3 it's not doing a whole
heck of a lot right now pawn to f5 just
trying to break up the Kings side of the
board he does have double pawns here so
he needs to be a little bit more
aggressive his opponents usually not
gonna take here on f5 that's not gonna
recapture right away we couldn't play
pawn to e4 now forcing the bishop to
move it maybe Bishop to e2 then you know
you could see something around castling
on the Kings side maybe Queen to d2 will
kind of go through these and then if you
wanted to take here Bishop on f5 you
know you definitely could but if we come
back instead of taking on f5 which
usually don't do
ended up losing somewhat of a tempo by
you know taking this and they just
recapture get a developed piece which
right now they don't have instead decide
to go and play Knight to see - so if
Fabiano wants to get that I involved
into the action and then pawn to f4 so
trying to gain a little space trying to
do something on board it's got a comp
ski but it's very tough right now he has
double Bishop pair but bishops really do
well when the board is open there's not
a lot of clutter in there so the board
and his pawns are actually doing a lot
of that cluttering right now so he needs
to start to break things up and really
start to control a lot of the board
which he's not doing right now 5a on Oh
Queen to h5 says hey if you're gonna try
to block me in a little bit and try to
put a lot of pressure I'm gonna start
getting more of my pieces involved into
the action knowing that you have a
weakened King side get my most powerful
pieces on board and see if I can wreck
shop on your side of the board pawn to
h6 I'm not up here to be for getting
ready to come back to the square on d5
which we've already talked about also
allows them to come up to c6 and put
pressure on the Queen side of the board
and Bishop to e6 is very very
interesting I'm not sure they gotta come
skate actually saw the pressure that was
on board and Fabiano actually has a
really nice decoy and if you wanna pause
and see if you could find the best move
but the best move and he found it is
actually just Knight takes on a6 the
route can't capture here on a6 I mean in
theory he could but then he's just gonna
lose to Bishop to b5 check the rook is
gonna fall so he does end up losing
material right there castles on the King
side which is risking it of itself but
it's no more riskier than just keeping
your King in the center of the board now
that I can just come back to b4 so free
pawn for Fabiano his setups better his
pawn structures a little bit better so
all-in-all Fabiano is kind of having his
way in this game and now calm ski looked
at the board and after a while played
pawn to f5 and f5 to me is kind of that
like Hail Mary I think a lot of this
stems from how he's played the
tournament so far having two losses
recognizing that he's in a bad spot and
he needs a miracle to happen
and so I think that's kind of what f5 is
you could play a lot more conservative
than f5 you could play just Queen to d7
make your opponent work forward castle
on the King side but the f7 kind of just
puts his self set we're just gonna blow
up the King side of the board see if my
opponent can make a mistake so we see
Castle is some protection right there
pawn takes on e4 if we see the bishop
recapture rook over here to c8 this is
semi open file that he can try to get
involved into the action but it's not
real clear how he's actually gonna get
past Fabiano's line rook to the one also
controlling a semi open file both of
these sides recognize and they need to
get their looks involved into the game
route down here to see for attacking the
bishop and then Queen here to g6 a
little more aggressive Square also
defending this Bishop on e4 gotta cops
he says you know what I'm gonna just
convinced myself that rooks are the same
as bishops and I'm gonna go ahead and
take here Queen recaptures I think that
is a terrible trade and then pawn to f3
Knight to d5 attacking the Queen not
really gonna see the bishop take because
then Queen takes here check and then you
know Fabiano if he could exchange all
the material down on board that'd be
great for him because you would have a
very easy in game so gata Kamsky can't
really start to exchange on board so he
decides to play down Queens to g5 very
easy to defend against that pawn here to
g3 rook f7 and then came to h1 he didn't
necessarily have to play King to h1 his
King wasn't under too much pressure
could have even just played pawn to h4
and then Queen here to h5 I think this
is fine but decided to go ahead and play
pawn or King here to h1 Bishop down to
h3 forcing the Brooke to move rook to e1
Bishop back here to f5 and then Queen
over here to be for now black recognizes
that he's gonna lose material this Queen
is attacking both the pawn here on b5
and aback Burke wanna d6 which was gonna
be a pain to defend the entire game he
decided to go and play a bishop back
here to f8 he's play more defensive that
he wants who wants to be aggressive but
recognize he needs to hold onto some of
some material white continues to gobble
up Queen here to a b5 pawn days 5-star
push on the kingside board but it's just
always Dewey is really pushing all of
his defenders more and more in front of
his King makes it even that more
vulnerable night here to e3 attacking
the bishop as you recall why it's fine
just exchanging all the material on
board because that's gonna be a very
very easy end game for him he has pawns
for days over on the Queen side that you
can push and he has the advantage in
material as well Bishop down h3 Queen 2
at c4 pinning down the rook Queen back
to a g6 and then the pawns start to push
pawn to a5 and there's just gonna push
up the board this rooks really holding
down the fort on the seventh rank but
besides that it's not gonna be doing too
much it's very tough to hold on to all
the pressure this pawn on the B phallic
has started to push as well King to h8 I
love the fact that gotta calm skis at
least trying to hold on and not just
resign right now which I think a lot of
players would do Queen to h4 Bishop
comes back to e6 pawn just continues to
push pawn to e4 ok solidifies this pawn
on f3 resolves my turn okay white
continues Queen to d8 queen or king to
h7 continues to push up the board Queen
to b6 and then pawned h4 and this is one
of those moves where I really don't like
it and if you look at the board you say
well there's not really a lot of good
moves that you potentially could like
but actually disagree I think there is a
move that I like and it is Bishop takes
on e3 not because blacks in a very good
position but because there's a chance
there's a chance a very a very very very
small chance that Fabiano completely
forgets how to play chess and instead of
taking with his rook on e3 he takes with
this pawn on e3 and then black wins the
game pawn to f2 there's no way to really
stop this you have the basic rook to f1
okay
Queen to f5 and we're coming down and
we're gonna checkmate you pretty fast
there's no way to really stop that if we
take on rook to f2 Queen takes this is
all bad there's no way to stop this
Bishop to h3 even if the rook comes we
do see a checkmate very quickly here if
we come back and say let's let's give up
some material here let's play rook to g1
that's that's fine as well let me let me
come back so here let's say you know
Queen to b5 is an attempt but that's not
that great rook to g1 now the Queen
comes back to f5 as we talked about
Queen to b3 trying to get involved into
the action that this Queen on b6 because
it's blocked by the pawn on e3 is a huge
pain right now there's no way to really
get into the action now just Queen down
to f3 you can see how this gets bad you
can always you know take the pawn or
take the rook here on g1
you could say well what if and say the
Queen coming down here maybe rook 2 to F
1 maybe this helps a little bit
now the pawn could just take we do
seeing exchange on board and this is
similar as we talked about Bishop down
h3 there's lots of variations they all
in very very poorly for white so that's
why I really just like the chance to try
to play Bishop to e3
there's not a lot of huge mistakes you
can make with pawn to h4 it decides to
play pawn to g4 I'm not sure why white
just didn't continue to push up just
says you keep doing your thing over on
the Kings side the board I'm just gonna
go ahead and get a free free can't or
pre Queen or if you just want to give me
your rook that's fine as well but
decides to go and play pawn to g4 Bishop
takes rook here to g1 says I'm gonna go
ahead and pin down this Bishop can't
move it I have my night and my rook
attacking that now that the bishop comes
down but that's just way too little too
late now the bishop can come down and
take that and after the bishop falls to
the queen on e3
then got a kick gotta come ski is forced
to resign in this position so Fabiano
finally gets on the board with his first
victory he's now moved up the
leaderboard and only half a game behind
the leaders so he does not have a loss
at all
I got a calm ski on the other hand has
three and he is struggling kind of
halfway through this tournament who's
gonna be looking to get back on track
but all all exciting chess both players
going forward with an unusual opening we
don't see that often and Fabiano just
completely completely outplayed his
opponents today
it did not seem like a fair fight but
exciting chess nonetheless hopefully you
guys enjoyed this round and I'll see you
in the next one thanks for watching